To this day, this shake remains one of the most well-known desserts at Mickey D's.
We're gonna start by putting two heaping scoops of vanilla bean ice cream into your blender.
Then we're gonna pour about a quarter cup of half-and-half.
Now, you could use milk but the half-and-half,...
...that's what makes it nice and creamy.
Then you're gonna add your peppermint extract.
Now, this is where it takes it from a vanilla shake to a shamrock shake.
Then put five to six drops of green food coloring.
Put the lid on and blend it for about 30 seconds until it's nice and smooth.
Pour it into a glass.
Put a dollop of whipped cream on top and don't forget the cherry.